and poverty is driving already poor
people to even more extreme measures
you don't have to see ahmed's face to
feel his anguish
they agree to me filming their scars and
some just a few months old we're
protecting ahmed's identity he still
worries about the safety of relatives
back home
these are decisions
for 12 years ah worked for the uk
government in kabul trying to help some
of his country's poorest
for him to see the sky news report about
how desperate things have become how
quickly his work was undone
is heartbreaking how do you feel
watching that video it's it's horrible
horrible scenes obviously we are here
physically but mentally all our focus
and attention and
is with people who we have been with for
for years and people who we have served
our relatives our families to see people
suffering now i think it's it's very
very i mean
[Music]
it's it's just uh i can't i can't
express basically feelings it's beyond
beyond expression
of words
ahmad says it's difficult not to feel
guilty to be here and safe with his
family while at home people are selling
their children for food forgotten some
say by the uk government who for so many
years invested so much and left so
little politicians are embarrassed they
feel defeated they feel humiliated they
feel the taliban one and they're trying
to
forget about afghanistan but the truth
is that this is something that we partly
own we have a deep obligation to the
afghan people but the uk government says
it has not abandoned afghanistan we are
working very hard first of all to bring
people out of afghanistan and we're
using various routes to do that we're
also putting additional humanitarian aid
into afghanistan as well as working with
international partners to secure the
long-term stability of the country and
what do you make of those reports that
people are having to sell their organs
well they're extremely extremely
concerning
last year more than 16 000 afghan
refugees were airlifted to the uk and
given asylum but none of those that we
spoke to felt enough help was heading
home
even if the uk government hits its
funding pledge of 286
million pounds that is still less than
was allocated in 2019
and remember back then uk and foreign
governments were still active in the
country supporting things like long-term
development projects that directly paid
public sector wages
foreign policy is for now blocking
direct payments like that choking age
routes leaving people so desperate they
will do the unimaginable to survive
cataracts sky news